we're now in the month of December 2017
the year is winding down so it's time
for the last of the update videos for
this year I'm going to talk about what
went on in November and what we've got
coming up in December as usual I like to
begin by highlighting three big things
that I want to bring to your attention
so the first of these is that I have
created a half-hour Hagel course site in
our reason I owe Academy which is a free
perk for our patreon supporters of the
half-hour Hagel project and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in in a few
minutes the second big thing is also a
course matter I was hoping to bring it
out last month but i'll be bringing it
out this month the same course that i
taught and developed for a college
online world views and values or recover
nine major thinkers talking about all
sorts of cool stuff from the nature of
human beings to society to cosmology
that is going to be coming out in the
reason I owe Academy so pay attention
and you'll see you know I'll put it in
my social media and other feeds and then
the third big thing is that later this
week I will have my last talk of the
year at the brookfield public library
and it is in this worlds of speculative
fiction series that I've been doing over
the entire year and this one we're
wrapping up by talking about George RR
Martin's song of ice and fire or for
those of you who just watch it on TV the
game of thrones series although they
diverge a little bit right so more about
that when i get to the december part
what went on in the month of november we
didn't have quite so many talks lined up
October was extraordinarily busy in that
respect in in November I just had to tow
acts and of course the usual half-hour
Hagel events the first talk turned out
to be extremely timely it was in the
philosophers in the midst of history
quarterly series that we've been doing
and I talked about Hana Arendt
totalitarianism and the Holocaust a rent
has been getting a lot of press recently
not least because of the election of
Donald Trump and people's worries about
totalitarianism so now they're finally
starting to read or rent which is a good
thing because she has a lot of very
useful things to say and she's a
cautious rigorous philosopher when it
comes to these sorts of things not prone
to shooting from the hip so I talked
about you know her views on Holocaust
itself on evil but also about the nature
of totalitarianism in her her works and
how she fit into that that very history
that she was sort of analyzing and
unpacking so that was the first talk and
you can see the video link to it below
the second totally different scene
although you know in some respects from
around the same time was on mervyn peake
who's a great fantasy writer also a
great artist he didn't he didn't produce
an awful lot of writing but what he did
produce is simply gorgeous so we talked
about the Gorman gasp trilogy that was
in the worlds of speculative fiction
series that we've been doing as a
monthly series and you can see the video
for that below as well I did a lot of
philosophical counseling and tutoring
work one-on-one with clients over the
course of November some of it spurred
admittedly because of the election and
the results and how people are reacting
to that i've also been doing a lot of
work on curricula and quite a bit of
this has been in the reason i owe
academy website which is on teachable
i'll put a link to that below we brought
out our first course for you know for
stoic week although i released it right
after stoic week because i didn't want
to steal any thunder on epic titus
that's a free course and we already have
over 350 students enrolled in it quite a
few of whom have finished the course
it's a very in-depth
look at that enchiridion of Epictetus I
also brought out this last month in
November the half-hour Hagel site as a
perk for those of you those of you who
are supporting this project on Patrian
and I'll just take a few minutes to talk
about that so the half-hour Hagel series
is this this you know very close reading
commentary on Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit and we're about halfway through
the work now after close to three years
of a video production nearly a hundred
and fifty videos produced and early on i
desire i decided to start crowdfunding
this and so over time we've accumulated
around you know forty odd people who
contribute every time that i publish a
video it de phrase some of the costs of
having me doing that work rather than
doing the other you know more
remunerative work that i could be doing
and it also produces a nice community of
inquiry of people that are really into
this understanding this great work so
this is a rather unique digital
humanities project i did something
similar by the way with Epictetus and
the enchiridion going line by line
through the work but Hegel's
phenomenology is a much longer much
denser work so i created this course
site for anybody who signs up as a
patreon supporter so if you would like
access to the course site for free as
opposed to paying 175 dollars for it
then you can become a patreon supporter
even at the lowest level and i'll give
you a coupon code that will let you into
the site and what we've got there's all
the videos organized resources access to
forums all sorts of really cool stuff as
a reward for for people to
you know engage in this this support so
that I've also been working on the world
views and values course I'd hope to
bring that out at the end of november
but as things have turned out it's going
to be in early December and I've been
working on other courses as well but
i'll talk more about that in the
december portion what else is going on
well I did some blogging I actually got
quite a bit of that done in our exes D&O
at DK my main blog and half hour Hagel
which is taking off quite a bit
surprisingly i'm getting more reads in
the half hour Hagel blog than I am in or
exes do know NTK over the last month and
I did a lot of video work as well you
know I did my quota of six half hour
Hagel videos which took us all the way
through the end of the law of the heart
Patrian supporters by the way one of the
perks is they get to see the videos as I
finish them whereas everybody else waits
you know anywhere from two weeks to a
month at this point in time I released
quite a few of the Aristotle core
concept videos that I shot for that
Aristotle course that I taught this last
summer and I did a personal video about
why I find stoicism interesting even
though I'm not strictly speaking an
orthodox stoic I do use quite a lot of
stoic philosophical practices and and
concepts in my work both as a
philosopher and as a philosophical
counselor I also released the videos of
my talks so that was quite a bit of
video work over over the course of that
month I'm also lining up talks for 2016
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that in the December section but I do
want to say we put in quite a bit of
work you know there's there's meetings
that you have to go to and going to send
out solicitations and follow up with
them and so we do have some some talks
already lined up for 2016 but we're open
to many more as well so if you're
interested in talking to me about about
booking me for inviting me into get the
talk or
shop or facilitate a discussion go ahead
and email me at Greg at reason I oh and
we'll see about getting something on the
calendar for either talking about it in
december or doing some talk in 2017 so
december is a month where we're winding
down on paper although it's still there
busy month if you if you see what's
going on behind the scenes and i'll tell
you a little bit about that as we go
through it first I want to talk about
events that we have coming up there's
there's two that are online that are
hagel related and then there's one
that's face to face the face to face one
is the last talk for the year which is
going to be on you know philosophical
themes and world building in George RR
Martin's Song of Ice and Fire is his
seven book at least projected series
five of which have been written
published released their the basis for
the Game of Thrones television show
which is now way off book that's
probably going to be a good bit of
discussion there this is our last talk
for the year it's at the brookfield
public library on December 8th if if you
live in the area and you can be there
we're going to have some really great
discussion i'm anticipating a fairly
sizable crowd for for this one because
martin is so popular and timely and
because there's a lot of cool stuff to
talk about so that will be on the 8th 7
p.m. at the brookfield public library
the other two events like I talked about
or online we have our regular half hour
hagel Q&A session that is on wednesday
december 14th at five p.m. central time
you want to make sure that you're on the
right time zone if you don't live in
central time if you're interested in
matters hagel related or you'd like to
know more about the course or anything
like that pop in this one will be a
google hangout after this year we're
going to be switching to to something
different when I could be using Google
Hangouts we're going to be using a
different format after
that that I'll link to on the
twenty-third for those of you that are
looking for something to do online I
will be having a Hagel holiday party
it's primarily for patreon supporters
but it's open to the public anybody
who's interested in that sort of thing
I'll be you know having a beer or two
and I'm happy to have everybody else you
know drinking whatever it is that they
particularly like and we'll chat about
philosophy about Hagel about the project
about the year to come about all sorts
of cool stuff that will be at two p.m.
central standard time on the
twenty-third if you can make it great if
you can't you know there's going to be
plenty more Hagel stuff coming so what
else do we have coming up in this month
and also in the year to come so I
already announced that we have the half
hour Hagel course on our teachable
Academy our reason I Oh Academy and
we've got now currently 11 people
enrolled in that not everybody who's on
Patriot is used the coupon yet but I'm
imagining that all of them will and if
you're interested in getting you know
free access to that course all it takes
is becoming a patreon supporter at the
one dollar per video level and you're in
you'll have access to all the videos in
a curated form which means you don't
have to hunt around for them so when
you're working at a particular part of
the text you can go right to that we
have discussion forums I'll be doing
Hagel events you know i'll be linking
all sorts of useful resources and other
cool stuff in there for you so if you're
interested in working your way through
this difficult text and you'd like an
expert guide and you'd like to be part
of a community of people also trying to
work their way through this text that's
something you might want to consider
later on this month i will be bringing
out the world views and values course
and that like i said is a course that i
developed and taught as part of an
online program
for a college and it had you know a lot
of people took it a lot of people liked
it people have seen some of the videos
for it and said i'd like to get access
to all the other stuff so that's what
i'm going to be providing there's lesson
pages there's handouts there's
discussion questions there's you know
quizzes all sorts of really cool stuff
who are the thinkers that we're going to
be going through Play Doh parts the
Republic Epictetus parts of the
discourses boethius is entire
consolation of philosophy de cartes
discourse on method Hobbes Leviathan
just some parts of it not the whole
network the entirety of Rousseau's
discourse on the origins of inequality
portions of Mary Wollstonecraft's a
vindication of the rights of women Karl
Marx's and Friedrich Engels Communist
Manifesto and Marx's alienated labor and
we finish up the course by looking at
Martin Luther King's I have a dream
speech and the letter from a Birmingham
jail so a lot of really cool stuff very
oriented towards social theory towards
understanding human beings and how they
live in society that's a course that'll
be coming out and during the month of
December and perhaps during during
January also produce a coupon for it
that will that will offer people a
reduced price so you want to watch for
that coming out what else so I'm doing
quite a bit of behind-the-scenes course
building in december for courses that
will be coming out in january and one of
those courses or one of those sets of
courses i'm actually breaking it up into
a couple different bits of course is
otherwise it's a little unmanageable is
on Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics so
this is essentially the course that I
taught last summer using all of those
core concept videos and handouts and
discussion questions and all that cool
stuff I'm adding some new stuff to it as
well
that is going to be three courses which
which can be bundled together a lot of
material there so I'm working on that
and I'm also working on a course I don't
know if I'll get it out during january
but but hopefully i will on Aristotle's
categories that that text that
instructors love to assign people and
say well you should start with this and
people read it there like what the hell
is this I have no idea what's coming on
so I'm building a course to help people
out with that and i'll also be posting
the videos for that eventually in
another channel i'm also in the process
of rebuilding and vamping up a course on
epictetus discourses that I've taught
twice now online once a long time ago
for the g KS once on my own reason i owe
using Moodle and now I'm going to be
producing it as a standalone class on
epictetus discourses for those who like
the Epictetus is enchiridion course this
is going to be you know sort of the next
progression and by the way I'm not
pledging to do this in January but over
the course of the year I'm going to be
having courses on other stoic thinkers
coming out as well and we'll probably
bundle them all together in one big
stoic package so you can you can look to
see some stuff at Seneca eventually some
stuff of Marcus Aurelius and some stuff
on the earlier stoics and cicero and
people discussing them so the ant is
reason i owe academy stuff i'm also
working on stuff for curious for those
who like micro courses he's much shorter
you know very quick to resolve courses
i've been developing stuff for them and
i should have some new stuff coming out
in january for that as well maybe even
in later december video work i'm going
to be doing some more half-hour Hagel
videos now we're actually in the virtue
in the way of the world section of the
phenomenology and
I should hopefully finish up with it by
the end of the year and we can start
moving into the next portion a reason
which is really cool we're getting close
to the end of that section more
Aristotle core concept videos i'm just
going to keep you know releasing those
because i would love to get through
those by the end of the year i have
quite a few of them still stocked up
we'll have the the video for the george
RR martin session of course and i'll be
doing some more personal videos over the
course of this month some along the same
lines of you know this phase that I went
through or why I'm interested in this
particular philosophy probably do want
on Hagel i'm guessing over the course of
this month i'm going to be doing more
blogging and i'm going to be working
with the same platforms are exes D&O at
TK and half hour Hagel in fact i'm
working on a piece on Rilke right now
that hopefully will come out later today
and if i get ambitious enough now that's
a big if you should hope to see some
stuff coming out on some of the other
blogs and platforms that that i have
written for or I'm intending to write
for so maybe maybe I'll have something
in heavy metal philosopher if I get it
finished hopefully something for
partially examined life I'm definitely
going to have some stuff for stoicism
today so you want to pay attention to
that and you know I'm looking at a few
other blogging platforms as well where
I'd be doing some guest blogging so
we'll see about that as I mentioned and
this is where i'll close we're still
filling the calendar up for 2017 we're
doing quite a bit of outreach and
marketing for you know spring and summer
in particular so if you're interested in
in booking me to come give a talk or
lead a workshop or anything like that
willing to travel
I have you know you know what sort of
speaker I'm like you can you can see the
videos email me at Greg at reason I oh I
will tell you for those of you who are
in the area I've already got
confirmation that we're going ahead with
those two series the quarterly series on
philosophers in the midst of history and
the monthly series on worlds of
speculative fiction I've also got a talk
on Mary Wollstonecraft lined up and a
few other talks much much later out in
some actually in the fall that i'm
scheduled to do so again if you're
interested in talking with me about you
know bringing me in to give a talk
whether locally or nationally or
internationally email me at Greg at
reason I oh good bit of philosophical
counseling coaching even some consulting
stuff and tutoring work in the month of
December again if you're interested in
those sorts of services you might want
to go to the reason I owe website or
again you can email me at that same
address Greg at reason I Oh calm and
we'll talk about it so a lot of stuff
going on behind the scenes and this is
the last update video that you're going
to see during this year in the next 14
january i'll talk about some of the big
picture goals for the year to come but i
don't want to jinx anything and i don't
want to talk about it any more of it
here because it's more important to
actually get the stuff done than just to
talk about it but that's that whatever
holidays you're going to be celebrating
in this this current month happy
holidays to you and hopefully I'll see
some of you in these these forums or
face to face or in other other ways have
a great end of the year and i'll see you
on the other side